it feels like the Big Bang Theory has
been topping the TV rating since the
beginning of time but it wouldn't be
around for much longer the sitcom
juggernaut about a group of nerdy
geniuses and their friend penny debuted
on CBS in 2007 and has only grown in
popularity over the decade it's still
massively successful as it heads into
his 12th season which will make it the
longest-running multi-camera comedy in
American TV history but the next season
will also be us last
how could CBS let this happen he has a
look at the real reasons a Big Bang
Theory is ending bazinga means I'm outta
here Jim Parsons was a character actor
best known for commercials and a minor
role in Garden States before he landed
the role of Annoying mega genius Sheldon
Cooper the show was made in not only
famous but also award-winning and
extremely rich in 2017 a Forbes reported
that he earns 27 point five million
dollars a year it's also made him an
in-demand actor and since he doesn't
have to worry about money Parsons can
take home whatever projects he wants in
recent years he starred in HBO's
adaptation of the normal heart and has
also appeared in a Broadway revival of
the classic play the boys in the band
after 12 years in one role Parsons is
ready to try new things how bad does he
want to spread his wings he may have
turned down 50 million dollars to stay
with the Big Bang Theory for another two
seasons so make no mistake he really
wants out Chuck's cool he is how series
co-creator and executive producer Chuck
Lorre announced the show was ending
according to Deadline Laurie summoned
the cast to his office after a table
read in late August where he let Parsons
have the room
Parsons tearfully told his cuffs mates
at the season they were shooting would
be as last Laurie then announced that
the twelve season would also be
everybody's last that's he had opted to
end the show rather than continue on
without Sheldon the decision have been
made just days prior with many
executives trying to convince Parsons to
change of mind when Parsons wouldn't
budge Laurie decided to put the show to
bed rather than attempt the difficult
task of reformulating it without one of
its leads he's had to do that before you
know Galecki going to Parsons isn't the
only one ready to walk away from the
series the show's other male leader
Johnny Galecki hinted in January 2018
but he was also ready for new things
sparking some early speculation that the
12 season the Big Bang could be the end
speaking to reporters he said we're all
going to be very sad when that day comes
but I think
at this point everyone's very
comfortable with 12 seasons being a good
time to go home and see our families
cost of doing business
TV series get expensive as they get
older with actors and mega successful
shows able to extract much more money
from their corporate overlords once a
shows taken off the network needs to
keep cast together and will offer actors
big money to make it happen the cast of
friends famously got 1 million dollars
each per episode toward the end of that
show's run just a bit more than a weekly
nine hundred thousand that Jim Parsons
Johnny Galecki and Kaley Cuoco will earn
in their show's final season in 2017 the
cast signed contracts for two more
seasons extending their commitments to
the spring of 2019 with the show's end
now being confirmed no one will have to
trouble with contract negotiations which
likely would have sent the cast members
salaries even more sky-high time to go
after the news here to kaley cuoco took
the winds to ground to share her
thoughts
Kuroko wrote that the series has been a
dream come true and does life-changing
as it gets no matter when it was going
to end my heart would have always been
broken into drowning in tears we promise
to bring you the best season yet Kunal
Nayyar shared his love for the show's
fans on Instagram right saying there are
no words in any language that can
describe what my heart wants to say the
love that I feel for you is boundless
Mayim Bialik expressed similar
sentiments on a personal blog writing
while the news was still fresh she
couldn't help but express disappointment
that a longtime job was ending writing
am I happy of course not but both the
news is hard to deal with she's still
ready to face it and move on the Big
Bang in future the end of The Big Bang
Theory doesn't necessarily mean that the
character of Sheldon Cooper will
disappear from television in full 2018 a
CBS will debut its second season of
young Sheldon a prequel show which
depicts the often difficult childhood of
a boy genius in a Texas town that
doesn't know what to make of him Parsons
is actually a part of that show's cast
as a serious narrator which he will
reportedly continue to do for at least
the immediate future
fortunately for CBS young Sheldon proves
successful in its freshman season but it
will still have a lot to shoulder as its
parent series heads off into that long
good night but even with that show
continuing it's a tough time ahead for
the CBS lineup as they work to replicate
the fortunes of a historically
successful show it all started with a
big bang
let's hope the show goes out with one
two
[Music]